so let's let's do this this is actually
an excellent opportunity to go into
we have we have the big news with tulsi
gabbard
uh it's called the breakup what is it
called break up big tech act
uh the bubta uh she's saying
these companies should not have 230
protections liability protections
if they're censoring people so just in
in we'll go into this in just a brief
second
this is the uh story from newsweek tulsi
gabbard backs trump in section 230
battle accuses lawmakers of cow towing
to big tech so
we've already seen and this story is
from you know couple days ago but
on youtube right now they just announced
a new rule about what you can and can't
say pertaining to
uh donald trump and accusations of fraud
it's really weird we had a really funny
discussion before
the show about like so i don't even know
if i can
say the uh the actual criteria because
it might be an algorithm just
listens and then nukes the show because
i said something too similar
but i'll try and break it up i actually
spoke with google on the phone
they said two criteria must be met for a
video to be removed
you must assert that there is widespread
voter fraud or error in this election
the next criteria that must be claimed
in the same sentence is that it changed
the outcome of the election
and that's it i asked for clarification
what what about changing the outcome in
terms of like
you know point one versus you know uh
you know minus point one like
the like the the winner isn't changed
but the numbers are changed and they
said
i think it's basically like if you claim
trump actually won because of these
reasons
and i'm like okay so if i say there is
evidence of widespread fraud
um and it needs to be investigated
but there's not it's not yet been as far
as i can tell
proven beyond a reasonable doubt that it
altered the outcome they said that's
okay
now i'm not entirely convinced that's
the case they may still nuke us for even
discussing it because
we don't know who these third-party
outsourced individuals who are reviewing
you know transcripts
what they're going to understand i get
routinely flagged for like ridiculous
things you know i did a segment talking
about
it was about some policy position the
video was like you know joe biden plans
policy around x and they said it was
hate speech
and then what i have to do is i have to
actually reach out to google and they do
a secondary review and overturn
personally because i guess they like me
you know maybe maybe they won't ban me
but these what they have third party
fact checkers they're you know in a
bunch of different countries all over
the place because youtube's massive
and they just here's the rule sheet and
they say yes or no
and so that's just bizarre though that
the total political discussion our
country is governed by
their third world outsourced that's
exactly it that they found
on fiverr.com their fiverr.com workforce
is
regulating our political speech or
robotic algorithms that take things out
of context
yes and can't understand sarcasm so
you know well they also i don't know if
we should even joke about it we had a
really funny joke earlier and i'm like i
don't know if i could actually say that
they still might
yeah i don't even know they can make the
joke because the joke might still
get to like a point of power it's just
time to stop joking i think
when you talk about certain things but
but there's like the
so there are certain jokes that are
obvious jokes to anybody but not to an
algorithm
because there there's intonation there's
inflection oh we should do a whole show
like you could you could say something
like
youtube so i'll give half the joke of
course
joe biden won he's the greatest
president in american history
already people are gonna hear them
they're gonna get on being sarcastic
he's not the greatest so that's the joke
i was making in the other episodes with
like
joe biden doesn't campaign he gets eight
million votes and he's like wow
think about the amount of charisma just
exuding an aura
it's almost like i if you're familiar
with dragon ball z how many dragon ball
z fans are out there
you know goku and he goes ah and there's
like a blast of energy coming out of his
body
joe biden stood up on that podium and
with one wink to that camera
it was like a nuclear bomb exploded
behind him the charisma was just
people sitting in their homes watching
their tv got knocked back like stuck
against the wall with the amount of
charisma
that's how joe biden was able to not
campaign and win 80 million votes
how are they going to campaign with when
the neural nets activated
i have no idea when we're all linked and
you won't need to because we'll be the
borg
i guess you just you already know who
you're going to vote for before they
even decide they're going to run
they're going to ban you from the neural
net so you're going to be one of like
you're going to be one of these like
um i don't know non-networked
individuals
and they're going to frown upon you
you're going to be like outside asking
people just spare a little internet can
you google search something for me
obviously the process will change
leading up to technology like that so
maybe we're just
in a fluctual process right now the the
issue is the unpersoning
and the and the suspension of political
discourse and especially
by non-american actors so i'll check
this out check this out
if you go on reddit.com and you go to r
slash
politics which is supposed to be
it's basically for american politics
more than half the people who are
commenting are probably in australia and
new zealand and europe
maybe not more than half but a good
portion so that means
americans are hearing more from foreign
opinions on our elections
and american citizens get suspended so
this is what i find is particularly
crazy and i'll use laura loomer as an
example
she ran she won her primary in florida
she's
a very controversial figure but she's
very good at getting press attention
she's been banned from every platform
but she is an american citizen who was
running for office and won a primary
still banned from all these platforms
but on twitter you can have
a hundred thousand people from australia
telling us how we should vote what we
what we should think influencing our
elections i'm not saying illegally
influencing
but that is worrying to me that these
people who don't live here
who don't understand the electoral
college who don't understand how our
representation works
don't understand how gerrymandering
works are influencing
people's opinions in negative ways
without understanding our country
that to me is terrifying especially when
you when you consider a lot of these big
tech platforms
like the risk we face right now by
having this conversation they've said
they'll ban it well that's not gonna
affect any democrat the democrats are
saying republicans are crazy
but there's there's there's evidence and
there's discussions to be had
they could ban us so that's negatively
impacting
conversations typically of the right yet
if you are australian
and you agree with democrats you can say
whatever you want but an american
citizen can't
that's insane
yeah i'm absolutely just sick of this
like
land of mine system where you have to be
careful with every little thing you say
i mean on my channel
i have to say the conholio sickness and
the jab instead of the
coronavirus and vaccine and i noticed
the significant difference
through my videos and the way that they
reach people when i say conholio
sickness
instead of coronavirus so there's
different algorithms there's different
people there's people in third world
countries that are literally hired
that have found to have a bias against
the lgbtq community
and there's a big outrage because a
whole bunch of like
trendy new wave woke craters were
getting censored and they're like what's
going on here
and it was a guy who was a religious
zealot in a third-world country who
hated them for for what they were
well we need to when you think about the
the results of what's currently
happening
with social media so everything i just
said about how an australian citizen has
more rights
because typically their opinions are
more likely to align with the democrats
right
so the us relative to europe and
australia is actually a bit to the right
and a lot of people keep saying in
europe america is so far right
the democrats are considered like a
centrist party compared to europe
and it's like i don't i'm not concerned
about the opinions of europeans because
they don't understand our system they
don't live here
and they don't under like there's a lot
of things they don't get about our
history why we have the certain systems
we do
it's not like one day we woke up and
said we want to create a broken weird
medical system
they had world war ii we had we all had
world war ii but they were most impacted
and they were
they were forced essentially to create
some kind of system to fix this it
doesn't
apply here but here what ends up
happening is
jack dorsey on the on the jorgen podcast
said we have to create rules for a
global community
and that means people in america who are
to the right of people in other
countries
may offend their delicate sensibilities
so twitter says
what's in the best interest of
maximizing our profits
we don't want just american users we
want european users so we can't defend
european users so ban those who offend
european users
democrats tend to offend them much much
less than conservatives who ban the
conservatives
now we can't have conversations in our
own country because they've
overtaken what's called the commons the
space where we used to communicate and
talk about public discourse and
it's and it's not just us and it's not
just random individuals but it's also
major uh journalistic institutions in
the united states like the new york post
that are literally having their accounts
taken away
for days because they release on a story
that now everyone is reporting on
but because the story was before the
election it was about hunter biden it
was about the son
of the democratic hopeful at the time
new york post got
censored and totally wiped off twitter
no one could even communicate with them
well
it is most um major evolutions that
become problems like this
are almost always the result of certain
government policies creating
for example in this case a moral hazard
here's the moral hazard and here's how
it was created
is that they have the ability to censor
anyone they want
but they don't have the responsibility
for what is published
on their site so they they have all the
power
but none of the responsibility that
comes with it and
the way 230 was designed and all these
things you either have one or the other
so let's say um
let's say you and i plot some a criminal
scheme and we talk to each other over
t-mobile the t-mobile network right well
t-mobile didn't censor us they didn't
publish us they're sort of you know so
they're not
you can't sue t-mobile for if somebody's
a victim of our crime they can't sue
t-mobile for being part of it right
so that's the protection that makes
sense for team now if t-mobile started
listening on conversations
and saying that's not an appropriate
conversation for you to have
well you think well now they have to
accept responsibility for what they're
relying on online
but what these socials have right now is
they have all the power
and other responsibility and one of
those two things has to go away the
problem is going to continue to get
worse and that's kind of the 230 reform
we need is that
look you are either a publisher yeah and
you have responsibility which is fine
but ban everybody but then if somebody
plots some scheme through your site well
you're completely on the hook for it and
they
that's the kind of reform that yeah i
think we need to look at so for those
that aren't familiar just to clarify
section 230 of the communications
decency act says that
no uh platform shall be considered to be
the publisher
of someone else's speech to simplify if
you go on twitter and post a comment or
tweet
that's your speech not twitter's i
completely and 100 agree with it
like if i make a phone call and and you
know if i group
call 100 people and then i say some
naughty word
that's not on t-mobile t-mobile is just
a phone company it's my speech i said
something if i call people start
defaming someone you sue me right
the issue is as you described it
translating this to twitter
or to youtube actually youtube
statements about what we can or can't
say pertaining to the election
is an editorial guideline not a
community standard now they've said it
was a community standard but that makes
no sense
no uh if 74 million people agree with
one idea and 80 million people don't
we clearly don't have a unified societal
concept like what is lewd in lascivious
section 230 provides what's called a
good samaritan provision for moderation
these platforms like youtube are allowed
to remove things and not be considered a
publisher
because it's good faith moderation if
someone posts
you know uh adult activities onto
twitter
and twitter doesn't want that then
section 230 says we're not going to
we're not going to consider you the
publisher because you're choosing to get
rid of these things that are
otherwise objectionable this is where
the problem arises
the language objectionable in section
230
define it that's the problem well
twitter or youtube would say
we think it's objectionable that anyone
would question the election
70 more 74 million people would disagree
in fact probably more than that because
there's been a couple polls now showing
that even democrats believe their their
there was fraud
and most republicans do so it's more
than 74 million
so when youtube says we find it
objectionable
perhaps under section 230 objectionable
could be a personal opinion in which
case
they are granted absolute and total
immunity as a publisher
to issue editorial guidelines on what
may or may not be published and never
face liabilities
which not even the new york times gets
you got to change the word objectionable
to illegal
yes and then you got to pick what state
that's in and i think right
this and typically the law would say
like the state but at which the company
is registered or whatever but yes so
that way
there is a challenge there right but i
think you can define
lewd lascivious and we're not going to
say a challenge in the election is lewd
that makes no sense we're not going to
say
it's offensive you might be able to
argue that but that still kind of
doesn't make a whole lot of sense and a
judge might be like what do you mean
it's offensive no it's not
objectionable means anything and that's
the reform we need
we need to get rid of that word absolute
lascivious like if someone pulls out
their genitals
well think about it this way let's say
uh the example i think we were given by
one of the guests was a christian blog
a website where christians and catholics
or whatever can come and have
conversations
and then someone starts posting a bunch
of adult activities
right well they're going to be like we
don't want center platform it's not for
this it's so that we can have you know
our our conversations
you can remove all that and still be
protected because it's clearly not in
the spirit it's a good samaritan
perspective if you change it to say if
only illegal content then they couldn't
remove that without becoming a publisher
exactly thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you